و هذا الامر يطرح عبء على الجنود
الاسرائيليين فيما يتعلق بكيفيه القيام
بهذه العمليات يحق لهم ان يقوموا بهذه
العمليات وان يدافع عن انفسهم
وان يزيلوا هذه القدرات من حماس عندما يتم
تخزينها في المستشفيات ولكن سوف اكرر ما
قلته سابقا عن هذه المساله نحن نتوقع ان
يقوموا بذلك فيما تماش مع القانون الدولي
وحمايه الاشخاص الابرياء في المستشفيات
التواق الطبيه والمرضى باكبر قدر
ممكن كيف تتلقون معلومات من الاسرائيليين
عن الخطط العسكريه ليس لدي معلومات
عن الاحاطه العسكريه ولكن كنا واضحين بشان
هذه
الامور لقد قيل مؤخرا ان الرهائن يمكن فقط
الافراج عنه من خلال وقف اطلاق
النار لقد راينا ان تمكنا من اخراج 100
رهينه من خلال رهاء من خلال وقف القتال
لمده اسبوع
ولا
يمكن انس ان نضع مسارا امنا لخروج الرهائن
اذا كان هناك اطلاق نار نحن بحاجه لالقاء
الاسلحه لوقت كاف لاخراج الرهائن والوقفه
لاسبوع واحد سمحت لنا باخراج م رهينه ومن
الواضح اننا ندعم الوقف في القتال من اجل
اخراج الاشخاص ولكننا لا ندعم وقف اطلاق
نار عام او دائم وهو عاده ما يتم بطريقه
يتم فيها التوقع ان يتوقف النزاع وان يكون
هناك مفاوضات لقد كنا واضحين بهذا الشان
ولم يكن هناك تغير بهذا الموقف لقد اوضح
الرئيس رايه فيما يتعلق بحل الدولتين
ولكنه قال ايضا ان نتنياهو منفتح الى هذا
الحال هل
نتنياهو قال ذلك للرئيس او لماذا قال ذلك
الرئيس لقد كان هناك حديث بناء جدا بينهما
وسوف لن اعلق على هذا الامر اضافيا الرئيس
يتحدث مع وزرائه وانا متاكد انه كان هناك
محادثات ولكن ما يمكنني ان اقوله هو ان
الرئيس يؤمن بحل الدولتين ولقد سمعتم عند
قال ذلك وقال انه متفائل بشان التواصل الى
حال الدولتين وطبعا يجب ان يكون هناك
مساومات للتواصل الى حال
الدولتين هناك اختلاف بوجهات النظر ولقد
قال نتنياهو ذلك علنا الرئيس فسر هذه
التعليقات العلنيه بشكل مختلف الرئيس
نتنياهو قال ان الرئيس رئيس الوزراء
نتنياهو لا يعارض حل الدولتين كيف تفسرون
ما اذا كان منفتحا ام لا لحل الدولتين
ساكر ما قلته سابقا لقد كان هناك حديث
بناء بين الرئيس بايدن ونتنياهو حول حل
الدولتين ربما هناك اختلاف الاراء فيما
يتعلق بشكل حل الدولتين ولذلك نحن بحاجه
الى قياض في هذه المنطقه للمضي قدما اذا
كانت هذه العمليه سهله لكننا قد حصلنا على
حل الدولتين منذ الكثير من الاعوام او قبل
الكثير من الاعوام ولكن هذا الامر يتطلب
مفاوضات وتضحيات من الجهتين والرئيس يفهم
ذلك ولذلك هو لا يزال على هذا
الموقف
س اسالك سؤالين في نهايه الاسبوع نتنياهو
عبر عن معارضته لحل الدولتين هل الاداره
لا تعتقد بانه حقا يعارض حل
الدولتين قد
خذنا محادثات صريحه جدا وسوف نواصل خوض
هذه المحادثات مع رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو
حول مستقبل الشعب الفلسطيني وما سوف تبدو
عليه غزه بعد النزاع وكما سبق وقلت سابقا
سوف يكون هناك اختلافات بالاراء ولكن سوف
اترك الامر ليعلق عليه رئيس الوزراء هل
البيت
الابيض كيف يمكن للبيت الابيض ان يتحدث
علنا عن هذه المواقف و ثم رئيس الوزراء
يعارض هذه
الاراء هذا ما لا نفهمه هل يعتقد الرئيس
انه سوف يتوصل الى هذا الحال بدون نتنياهو
الشعب الاسرائيلي هو
الذي يختار قادته
وثانيا الرئيس يعلم ان هذه العمليه صعبه
ولقد تبين لنا ان هذه العمليه كانت صعبه
جدا حتى اليوم ولكن انه يعتقد انه من
مصلحه اصدقائنا الاسرائيليين ان يكون هناك
دوله فلسطينيه
مستقله سوا كان سوف يكون هناك جيش في هذه
الدوله ام لا نحن لا نعلم ذلك ولكنه لا
يزال يعتقد
باهميه تاسيس هذه الدوله وسوف نواصل خوض
هذه المحادثات علينا ان نتذكر ان اسرائيل
تخود معركه صعبه مع حماس وعلينا ان نضمن
ان اسرائيل سوف تتم من الدفاع عن نفسها
يوم الجمعه سئلت عن مراهق امريكي فلسطيني
قتل في الضفه الغربيه هل لديك اي معلومات
اضافيه عن هذا الوضع وكيفيه تفسير هذا
الوضع هل الوزير تواصل مع عائله المراهق
انا لا اعلم ما اذا كان هناك تواصل مع
العائله سوف اعود الى هذا السؤال لاحقا
انه سؤال جيد سوف نحاول ان نحصل على
المزيد من المعلومات عن ذلك طبعا مقتل هذا
الش شاب كان حادثه ماساويه ونود ان نرسل
احار التعازي لعائله هذا الفتى الذي يبلغ
من العمر 17 عاما نحن نفكر
بعائله هذا الفتى وندعو الجهات
الاسرائيليه لان تقوم بتحقيق كامل وشفاف
بملابسات مقتل هذا الشاب ونحن نامل انه
سوف تتم محاسبه من قتله 17 عاما طبعا
اوقات ماساويه بالنسبه للعائله فيما يتعلق
بالاجتماع في الاسبوع الماضي حول اوكرانيا
هنا في البيت الابيض المتحدث باسم البيت
الابيض قال ان الرئيس لم يتحدث عن
استراتيجيه واضحه لاوكرانيا هل البيت
الابيض استراتيجيه واضحه و ما هو الهدف
النهائي بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا لا
يمكنني ان اعلق على ما تمت قراءته او
فهمه فيما يتعلق بالمحادثات المتعدده مع
الكونغرس حول اوكرانيا لقد كانت هذه المحا
ا هذا جون كوربي منسق الاتصالات بمجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي متحدثا